esta vez quiero reflexionar sobre
algunas preguntas comunes en las
escuelas por ejemplo los estudiantes con
frecuencia preguntan por qué cuando
trabajamos con álgebra utilizamos letras
y no sólo números bueno esa es una muy
buena pregunta sí porque usamos tantas
xy es a veces cuando estamos iniciando
el trabajo con álgebra voy a dejar un
momento para que tú puedas reflexionar
acerca de esto
bueno a mí me gustaría empezar a decir
que a veces tenemos una incógnita
por ejemplo cuando digo x 3 es igual a
10 y cuando planteamos un problema como
éste es porque en realidad tenemos una
incógnita algo que no conocemos y
queremos resolver pero no necesariamente
tendría que ser una equis porque este
espacio más 3 es igual a 10 o la
interrogación más 3 es igual a 10 bueno
podríamos utilizar una carita sonriente
también una carita sonriente más 3
igualdad 10 necesitamos algún tipo de
símbolo que representa un número ahora
podríamos resolver la ecuación y saber
qué es lo que representa ese símbolo
claro que sí previamente ya supiéramos
de qué se trata pues entonces no sería
una incógnita y otra situación sería
cuando queremos establecer la relación
entre números
por ejemplo digamos si yo estableciera
esta relación de si tú me das en un 3 yo
te doy un 4 y si me das un 5 y un 6
si me dieras un 7.1 yo te daría un 8.1 y
esto podríamos seguir extendiendo lo
siempre siempre siempre o sea que tú me
dieras un número y yo te regresara otro
número
obviamente se ve que aquí no me
alcanzaría ni el espacio ni el tiempo
y entonces podríamos plantear de otra
manera este asunto por ejemplo si lo que
tú me das le llamamos equis y lo que yo
te doy le llamamos y observemos que
ahora esta simple ecuación me establece
la relación de un infinito número de
números muchas xy muchas veces por
ejemplo alguien puede decir bueno si tú
me das 3 le agrego 1 y te regreso 4 tú
me das 7.1 yo le agrego 1 y te regreso
8.1 y esta es una manera elegante de
representar las relaciones usamos xy por
razones históricas y podríamos utilizar
por ejemplo si tú me das una estrella yo
te regresaré digamos una carita
sonriente y esta es una manera válida de
trabajar o sea las letras son
simplemente símbolos